good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy oh my
happy wednesday everyone happy hump day
hope everyone's having a great hump jay
hey jax how you doing i'm doing good i
can't believe it's only wednesday
honestly it shouldn't be a thursday it
really should be saturday maybe because
i've been podcast podcast podcasting all
week vlogging redheads
tmt never ends and it just feels like
i've done i've done way more episodes
this week than days of the week that
have passed but
it's just one of those weeks you know
leading up to the holiday weekend you
got to get it all in
that's what i like to call mogul energy
yes
this is mogul energy exuding and mogul
energy is exhausted energy
i was up so late editing last night's
episode of the redheads that we recorded
it's an hour and a half the girls could
not stop talking it's such
a different episode because obviously
we're recapping the book that we read
but the book that we've read is like
really um reflective on your 20s and
just like
it's about your in i don't know it
wasn't plot driven it was character
driven and it's all about like
the person that you are and all the
things that make you and so it was very
personal honestly
jackie that's beautiful
i know so it was it was raw and i hope
everyone really likes it i finished
editing last night which i'm so happy
about so i'll be out tomorrow morning
bright and early you know the redheads
we rise and grind those episodes drop at
7am you're extremely scheduled and
regimented and i think the redheads
community appreciates that yeah because
that's the sort of
consistency that the community demands
because like these are people who are
reading books like i'm gonna read this
whole last book just for your episode to
be coming out
no and that is something i'm seeing a
lot just like as an observer of social
media culture
it's like if you have a weekly podcast
and maybe this is just like i can be
judgmental because i have a daily
podcast and for the most part we get it
up um but like you're doing a weekly
podcast and people are always like oh
today's episode's gonna be up tomorrow
or i didn't record this week like what
yeah
like you have one job and get the
episode up i'm saying that a lot i'm
seeing a lot of lazy energy for my for
my comrades but maybe that's also just
summer energy
maybe but the excuse runs out
this week and next week obviously it's
the first week after labor day first
week back at work but i'm also seeing
like i saw a headline that goldman sachs
is making all of their employees i don't
know why goldman sachs has become like
the go-to for what's going on hr in the
office across the country but like every
time they do something it becomes news
right every employee back in the office
after labor day no excuses no part time
from home like it's over
oof that sucks
i mean two and a half years later going
on three years of this it's time to get
back to work
like i guess but i do think what we've
learned from these last two three years
is that like you can work a full-time
job and like if you're remote like you
can travel like you can have a
fulfilling personal life
too which i feel like people really need
like certain jobs especially [ __ ]
goldman sachs like you have no time for
anything else you know yeah i would say
that's a good point but i do think um
people and people need work and they
need obviously work balance but they
also need to be able to travel and do
things for their mental health but i
feel like the last two and a half years
everyone's been working from home and
mental health is at an all-time low
that's true that's true um because of
like the quarantine of it all yeah like
you're supposed to
go out every day get dressed yeah see
the sun
you know have
fresh air all of these things are
important to living a good life for sure
but i do think this concept of like you
know
traveling but not being off is like a
thing like now that we've proven like
you can fulfill all your
responsibilities while you know maybe
going to miami and working from there
like that should be an option you know
for like these new media companies yeah
i think it is an option but i would
actually argue that
that makes the prob that exacerbates a
lot of these issues like you need to
have time off like i feel like back in
the day you used to work from nine to
five and and you had to be in at nine
but you left at five and your day was
over and i mean back in the day like 80s
you know working before cell phones
emails you couldn't have email on your
cell phone like at five o'clock the day
was over now the day never ends because
you're constantly expected to be on and
now that goes into vacation too like you
should have you should take a vacation
you should take the time off you should
put on your ooo and you should not be
disturbed so you can actually recharge
and not just be answering emails on the
beach i learned about that in my media
class it's called personal autonomy
nobody has personal autonomy anymore
because
you're technically always on the clock
when you work like with emails right the
plus side to that though is that it
allows you to maybe mosey into the
office at 11 because you've been on
email since nine and your mouse was
moving on team so i said you were
available so everything is pros and cons
yeah it really is and you can make the
argument for either and i know every
time i talk about people going back into
the office i get yelled at and that's
fine
come for me but
that's how i feel and i think it's good
okay i feel like mixed about it i
definitely think that you know
consistently working from home is good
for nobody's mental health and there's
no boundaries between like personal
space
office space um but i do think there
were some good things that came out of
it honestly and like i think the way
that like our jobs are like something
you know you have to do like forever in
order to live like so [ __ ] up
well that's why if you love what you do
it's better for sure no yeah because i
don't agree with if you love what you do
you'll never work a date because i
absolutely love with what i do i don't
have one com i mean i i could you know
drum up some complaints but i really
don't have complaints about what i do
and even i wake up with my alarm and i'm
like no yeah
so i do love what i do but it still
feels like work it's just good it's fun
yeah
but
then do you ever feel like whenever we
have a long weekend or something and you
didn't go away but we're just like home
and not doing episodes that you almost
miss it
oh no i didn't think that's what you
were gonna say no
i was gonna say do you ever feel like
when it's a long weekend and you don't
do anything you stay at home like that's
what life would be like without a job
but it's not good i mean of course no
it's not good exactly first it's good
and especially in between large
stretches of working it's good but to do
that every day no that's not a
purposeful life that's like everything
not everything is meant to be enjoyed
all the time but doing hard work it
gives you a sense of purpose and that
gives you a sense of self and that is
important yeah no i wasn't saying it
like a positive thing like being at home
and this is coming from someone who
like i worship my home i can't spend
enough time there it's low-key boring
and if that's like your same [ __ ] every
day very monotonous like it's not a
purposeful life a hundred percent and
there have to be bad parts of life so
you can appreciate the good parts yeah
so i get it but like i just think it'd
be cool if nobody had to work you know
like a utopia
okay you sound like
like a socialist
like is that why like
yeah i guess it's like giving ki boots
energy
but like i just think like everyone
hates working and like we should do
something about that you know
yeah but that just counters what you
just said which is that when you're not
working no i know i'm saying i feel both
ways i'm feeling like yeah for sure it
would be boring but like let's try um
that's new for you feeling both ways
is it no i'm kidding oh yeah okay we
feel both ways about everything i feel
like you're saying too
right i see
both sides i just i happen to feel a
little more strongly that way
am i
a socialist i'm extremely social so that
makes sense yeah
and i've spent many times on ki bootzes
that's actually not your vibe
let's talk about aki boots a lot of
people don't know one of the core
tenements
of socialism was like started in israel
because in israel they're like a lot of
people live on kibbutzes which are like
these little communities that um
as a young person like if you go and
visit which when we were like in middle
school we went to israel and like they
have you live on a boots like really
experience what life is like there and
it's like a totally socialist little
commune where you know nobody really um
everyone's the same like everyone works
different jobs but they're all like the
same level of difficulty and you earn
the same wages according to the visit
for each according to his ability to
each according to his need
okay so um
they're very not um luxurious if if
that's a right way of putting it um i
have experienced time on a kibbutz the
schnitzel was good i will say and they
had rice which is my favorite food
so i don't have complaints about the
food but like everything else it just
like wasn't for me so maybe i'm not a
socialist well you know what and also
like you were coming into this oh sorry
i'm not a socialist i'm a social light
you were coming into the ki boots as a
tourist like you weren't toiling right i
was getting like a good treatment
they were treating me well i don't think
that's what it's like usually like
and people in israel it's like a cult
like they love key bootses i'm like no
not for me
and i think there are experiments
experimental communities in the states
that have a similar
energy to kibbutz vibes
um
and sorry when i said socialism started
in israel i don't think that's right no
it's not karl marx marx right yeah he's
not israeli okay sorry but like they
they uphold a lot of socialist vibes
over there and their kibbutz's is what i
meant yes um i don't want people coming
for me like claudia
you think everything the jews invented
everything well karl marx was a jew but
okay
he was i'm pretty sure
it's like such a um actually it is a
pretty jewish last name carl with a
catos doesn't give jewish energy yeah
it's a big yikes for us
yeah that's um
wow i didn't know that so maybe the jews
maybe the jews did invent socialism uh
this episode has just taken taken a turn
such a term i wasn't brushed up on my
socialist history today no one thing
about apologies if i've gotten anything
wrong one thing about me i literally
have no idea what like socialism or like
these big isms are you know like
i know capitalism is like about
business and money
socialism is about like the pie right
like everyone gets the same slice
yes
four each according to his ability to
each according to his need
okay you keep saying that like it's
going to ring some sort of bell okay
like
oh right
yeah
the need i don't know i literally say it
again i still won't know like from each
according to his ability no i understand
it is that a phrase from something it's
from the communist manifesto i think
by karl marx
by karl marx wait now i'm okay i'm
googling karl marx he has german
ancestry but he was a lapsed christian
oh and he's an atheist and an
anti-semite great that's really good to
know that's that's so us getting
confused whether a person is jewish or
anti-semitic you know because it's
really tough to tell you're either one
or the other you're either one or the
other yeah
so
sorry about that
correction
update alert
alert
okay so i have to go down this rabbit
hole how did we get into this
conversation oh that people are going
back to work yes labor day weekend the
fun is officially over next week so
enjoy this weekend while you can you
guys
breathe it in get fresh air hang with
friends have a beverage just
it's not going to be fun for a few
months until christmas season we're
almost entering that season and i'm like
i'm excited yeah i'm personally here for
it and if i may if you are going back to
work and maybe you're going back five
days for the first time in two and a
half years may i share some of the pros
that i see in like corporate culture
that maybe could get you excited sure
free food free food
outfits it's like why don't you watch
you know younger or the bold type those
out those shows like get me excited
about going getting dressed up getting
dressed up going into work where are we
going for lunch let's go you never know
who you could meet you know like a sexy
man from the business department yeah
let's go for after work drinks make a
plan for a happy hour already don't get
like too drunk or that will ruin the
rest of your week don't
maybe like set up a date this week so
you go to happy hour drinks after work
and then you like go on a date like this
is like what life is supposed to be
right the the intra office drama yeah
it's gonna be fun and then you'll have
you great stuff striper deer toasters
right she's our advice segment that we
have today too yes we do it is wednesday
that's a good call i thought you were
gonna say one of the
pos like one of uh i thought you were
going to suggest
um things to help people who are in the
workplace by signing up for our patreon
that's what i thought you were going to
do definitely that also we're here for
you we're doing the show
if you did take the summer off you
probably didn't listen to all our
episodes go back and listen honestly
this has probably been our funniest
summer on record
100 percent and if you are a toaster and
you know what i think we should talk
about it let's talk about it i want to
talk about like the state of the toast
but if you are a toaster and you miss
some episodes like please go back and
watch because we're really proud of them
we're hashtag proud yes so i was
actually i feel like we had this
conversation when i was in florida but
i've been thinking about it a lot
recently
because
like the vibe of this show has changed
so much and not in the sense of like the
structure or anything we've done the
same thing for every show since we
started but definitely the um the vibe
you know
the conversation the tone the tone
um and i feel like when we first started
honestly i cannot believe people used to
watch our episodes in the pink studio
like we were literally not funny i think
we were so afraid of like saying the
wrong thing
um that we were just like kind of being
like losers like every story it was like
we're so happy for them like actually
i'm not
you know
so now that i feel like we've gotten
more comfortable and like it's been a
long time we've really established our
brand and we've had you know people come
people go people stop listening stop
start listening restarting now we just
feel really set and that really gives me
the freedom to say whatever the [ __ ] i
want including the fact that i might be
a socialist you know
you know what that's not a hot take
these days you'll probably get a lot of
yeah no i think socialism is i think
it's like trendy now like if i say i'm a
capitalist and you say you're a
socialist let's see who gets more hate
okay yeah i want to be the popular one
so
whichever one that is like i choose a
dangerous one because i'm not afraid of
a challenge okay l you're such an l and
i'm such a vivian like jealous wench
no but back to what you were saying i
agree with everything and i also think
it's
um it's a testament to how long we've
done this show but it's also just us
growing up in general and just being
more confident women more sure of
ourselves and not letting people
opinions of us
change what we do or how we move yeah no
and at the end of the day like
i'm really just feeling like i want to
say how i feel like
if i don't support women like that's how
i feel you know what i mean and like for
the most part like i don't support women
you know
[Laughter]
like and i just feel like that needs to
be said like are you cool then i'll
support you you know like are you guys
but i don't believe in blind female
support um and that kind of that is
something that definitely came with age
you know yeah yeah so i feel like the
tone of the show has definitely changed
recently um and i think that has to do
with us changing
and i feel really good i feel i agree
like this was our funniest record to
date nope everybody's summer today
audience now is just like loving it
maybe our audience has changed i mean
it's constantly changing people come in
out depends on the season of your life
you know
sometimes you need us sometimes you
don't right um
but that feels great
i feel good and the summer is coming to
an end and this is kind of uh
us commemorating that yeah our funniest
summer yet what do you think is in store
for us for the fall
i'm hoping for you know vibes cultivated
lots of chili
lots of good books lots of good tv to
recap
um and stunning looks from both of us
that's what i'm hoping for i love that
i'm looking forward to um
not to be toxic but going on a diet
that's fine yeah i'm actually not
looking forward to it every time i tried
to eat healthy recently i've been
feeling like so queasy but
i don't think that what you should say
is that you're looking forward to going
on a diet you're looking forward to
getting back in shape
sure
sure because you're not looking forward
to like what you're actually gonna be
eating you're looking forward to how
you're gonna feel having you know my
body be my own again and then doing what
i want to do because i'm finishing up
breastfeeding this week and nursing
which is so bittersweet but then i can
you know get back to and i'm looking
forward to getting into some of my
clothes again like i'm wearing some
clothes today not everything is zipped
i'm not gonna lie that's that's the
beauty of podcasting from the waist up
so your pants really don't need to be
buttoned
yeah so i so every job has benefits you
know some people get health care vision
care dental care
we don't have to button our pants and i
feel like put that in your copay
what's the phrase like put that in your
hat and your pipe and smoke it
put that on your copay and smoke it yeah
yeah
so that's the state of the toast we're
feeling really good about it um
and should we continue to do some more
toast yeah that fast five times
in your life since you know yesterday
was just so busy for me working getting
ready for my trip um i have nothing like
unique or funny to add okay great
so without further ado
where are you where the [ __ ] are the
streis brothers i don't know where bryce
is bryce is done with the show he's
walked off set he's on strike i don't
know what he's looking for better
conditions like he wants a juicier
blanket in here
so now that he's gone i think like we
can have an open and honest conversation
about how i felt like his presence here
was extremely toxic like between the
barking the scratching at the door like
he doesn't understand we're recording a
premium audio experience he never did
that he would sleep right here like a
precious angel he's literally done he
barked once like
living breathing dog
i think in general bryce adds more value
to the show than he takes away but he
doesn't want to do it anymore he's i
mean maybe he's just taking our advice
and he's ooo listening to his body he's
ooo he can't be reached via email
[ __ ] off
[ __ ] off
okay so
mr strice brothers hopefully they come
back one day
and now it's time for the fastest maybe
maybe were the toxic ones like maybe we
have a toxic work environment and that's
why all of our employees are leaving
first bryce and streis
huh
is
buzzfeed about to write an article about
our toxic work environment
this is where dogs released a statement
from like you know the two founders
and like they're going to leak our slack
messages to bryson's trace like get your
ass up and work and mine are going to be
like really kind of bestiality focused
and then i'm going to be painted
they'll make a highlight clip of every
hump day thing every time you said that
you were gonna hum theo
and then side by side with like some
direct messages i sent to theo on like
my work server like hey cause i
literally i'm like hey sexy that's what
i say to theo i'm like you wanna get
your sexy little ass over here
oh my god well that actually has
something to do with one of our stories
today so oh bestiality
inappropriate workplace conduct oh okay
so without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
mcdonald's here at the morning toast it
is no secret that we are obsessed with
mcdonald's after a long day of podcast
podcast podcasts meetings meetings
meetings is there anything better than a
mcdonald's fountain diet coke a large
crispy french fry and their iconic
chicken sandwich no
how do you take your mcdonald's chicken
sandwich you do the standard the spicy
the deluxe you add pickles you remove
the pickles you add sauce you had
ketchup what do you do for me i know
like everyone thinks i'm a freak i just
like bun chicken ketchup because i'm a
three-year-old but however you like it
it's more personal than comedy and
there's no wrong way
to create your own
chicken sandwich from mcdonald's
you can order a head on the mcdonald's
app try the sandwich that invented the
crispy juicy tender today at
participating mcdonald's the app
download and registration is required
and today's episode is also brought to
you by clinique if you have dark spots
it can often feel like a vicious cycle
as soon as one fades another one pops up
break the cycle with the clinique even
better clinical dark spot interrupter
their powerful serum works from fair
skin to melanin rich skin and it helps
visibly correct dark spots such as acne
marks while protecting from future
discoloration
so 94 of people demonstrated an
improvement in radiance and visible skin
tone including acne marks in just eight
weeks you can see a 39 visible reduction
in dark spots in 12 weeks so what's so
great about it is that it's oil free
alcohol free sls free sulfates free
parabens free flavolates free fragrance
free it's also oil-free non-acnegenic
and it's fast absorbing it was developed
by dermatologists clinique is a brand
that we've all known forever our
grandparents have used it and it's just
premium as hell it's a brand that you
can trust and dark spots are so
difficult to get rid of and i have been
using the serum now for almost two
months and i've definitely noticed a
difference my dark spots get really bad
in the summer so you can get the even
better clinical dark spot interrupter
today it's available at clinique.com
thank you claudia
you're welcome our first story leonardo
dicaprio and camilla marone break up
after four years their hearts will go on
leo and camilla have called it quits
after four years together according to
people sources confirmed the split to
the outlet but a reason for the reported
breakup was not given it is worth noting
that camilla recently turned 25 and leo
has not dated someone over 25 i think in
his whole life so the reason for the
breakup was her recent birthday
that's like what the memesters are
saying she's aged out of the program
she's aged out of the program he's not
interested in um women with fully formed
frontal lobes brains
so she had to go
um well she lasted a long time let's
what they started dating when she was 21
yeah i really thought that this was it
for them and i didn't
you didn't no
i mean i really it's right there plain
as day that someone like put together a
graphic of how he ages you know trending
in a lot of words and all of his
girlfriends from giselle bar raphaeli
like lively
every single one he never goes over 25
with that's like there's been a few that
hit that number [ __ ] weird like
honestly
and
i just can't believe that like
he would actually like like he should
have waited till she was 26 like just to
show people wrong but maybe he really
can't stand a 25 year old woman i think
part of the reason why people might be
shocked by this um was because they were
together for so long i don't think he
ever dated any of those girls for as
long or started dating them as young
um so part i think a lot of people
thought that this might be you know it
for leo um
it's not how old is leo now
leo is 40 um
i think he's 42 but let me just confirm
that
that
is unique
yeah let me confirm
also have you been seeing these
rumors that he's dating gigi
he's 47. he's 47 oh my god
no i haven't seen the rumors that he's
dating gg how old is gigi gigi's older
than than 25 yes
she might even be like close to 30 i
feel like she's my age
she's 27.
oh my god she's younger than me like
just kill me now um
stop are you really
stop
i'll stop
for like seriously shut up i didn't say
anything
say
[Laughter]
am i 28
yeah there's no getting around that
um
i have not seen the rumors that he's
dating gigi and while i would ship it's
still [ __ ] weird like 20 years get a
life like there are beautiful sexy women
who you actually might have something in
common with
who are in their 30s i'm not even saying
you have to date someone in their 40s
30s
yeah a 35 year old like come on
it's it's weird and now i'm like
in the camp of
he won't date a woman over 25 doesn't
want a fully formed
female companion
but you know i feel like i think cami
marone is like so everything of the sort
i feel like
this relationship was like so good for
her career she's like you know i think
she is the face of chanel she gets
really premium acting roles i believe
she's going to be in daisy jones right
she's playing camilla and daisy jones
who's camilla she
so you know how daisy like there's a
lead singer of the band that daisy joins
the six yeah he's like billy or
something anyway yeah billy's wife is
right i remember i remember
um i love that and i think like
she's great
and i look forward to seeing what she
does next but i'm glad we're all having
this conversation because you know we'd
love to talk about it with like scott
disick and for a while leo like goes
under the radar and it was just like a
thing people know but never really spoke
about how [ __ ] weird it is in
borderline unethical
but now we've said it but now we've said
it and i guess the difference is like at
least he has these long-term
relationships which is something as
opposed to scott who's like in
cycling through 18 year olds
in a way he never gets to 23 24
jackie in a way it's worse
because
the long-term
nature of the relationships like
give like grooming vibes
right the grooming
yeah it's just weird like i would love
to see him date someone
slightly older i'm not unreasonable you
don't need to date someone 75 like
35 at this point the bar is just 20 26.
yeah right right like that's weird
i do forget that there was a time when
blake lively and leonardo dicaprio were
dating i was and that was a while ago so
he was probably like 37
no i think it was more than that he was
younger than that but oh but so
giselle
right
and they dated for like
more than five years i think
and then bar raphael like every
girlfriend that he's had has been like
that's his long-term partner but there's
been like six of them
yeah
and like what is he gonna do is he gonna
do the george clooney thing who was also
like doing long-term relationships but
never settling down and then literally
we all blinked and he's married with
twins in italy probably
yeah do you think he's gonna go like you
know the lawyer businesswoman route leo
or like an actress i think like an
environmentalist
totally maybe
i was just gonna make the most
disgusting joke and i will not make it
i'll tell you after it's
so funny oh can't wait yeah that's fine
should i say it yeah you can always cut
it out
he's gonna date an environmentalist
maybe he'll wait till that girl greta is
18.
that's a good because she's so young
like i know that's like inappropriate
but it was like a funny joke that's
really funny and
not
entirely not out of the realm of
possibility not out of the realm
right because what is she now 16 i could
see in like five years dating her
but the thing about greta is that she is
principled and i don't think she would
fall for it i don't think so either but
it's leo like
he would like try and hit on her and she
would be like how dare you
are we gonna have to cut this out like
is this really inappropriate i know and
i don't think so how dare you
i love that [ __ ] like she is so [ __ ]
like she's not even doing it for
she's not even doing it to be funny but
like she's so [ __ ] funny well she's
also a change maker but she's also like
unintentionally
a comedian
how dare you
that was iconic literally iconic
so funny so we'll keep our eye out for
that
but honestly
stranger things have happened right
right like
what movie was i recently watching
where they had like a greta gerwig girl
younger
grunhoff
yeah
that was funny episode yeah are you
ready for our next story yeah younger
yeah yeah
so funny are you ready for our next
story
um
the chickens might be coming home to
roost for dan schneider
oh my god i'm like we're talking about
chickens
like a farm i was so the chickens are
coming to roost on this indiana farm i
literally thought that's what you're
going to say
no
yes i saw this dan schneider is the
subject of a new um report from insider
saying that nickelodeon allowed
sexualized victorious scene with daniela
monet despite her complaints as network
stars claim producer dan schneider
pushed for inappropriate content
so there's an insider article that just
came out about some of dan schneider's
more inappropriate practices while he
was at the helm at nickelodeon the
article is behind a paywall but daily
mail has a summary
former nickelodeon stars are speaking
out against the prolific creator and
producer dan schneider for allegedly
forcing the young
actors into quote sexualized scenes in a
new report for insider the victorious
actresses daniela monet claimed that a
scene that she was uncomfortable with
was left in the final cutting of an
episode despite her objections to the
network although she doesn't solely
blame schneider who was the creative
executive producer and writer on
victorious she also blamed nickelodeon
for allowing sexualized scenes
in its live-action shows and for
inappropriate behavior to occur on set
100
the actress described reaching out to
the network after she was forced to film
a scene in which she applied lipgloss
while eating a pickle which she worried
was too sexual to be broadcast on the
kid-centric network but nickelodeon
executives apparently sided with dan
schneider and the creative team over
daniela monet and the scene was included
in the episode she added that not only
did the executives okay the scene but
its standards and practices division
would have had to sign off on it as well
she attributed some of the overly sexual
content to the mostly male writers on
the show she said that although
victorious was usually a very pc funny
silly friendly chill place the
occasional over sexually overly sexual
scene could puncture the warm
atmosphere she said do i wish certain
things like didn't have to be so sexual
sexualized yeah a hundred percent
insider's expose notes that some of um
that quote none of dan schneider's shows
credited more than two female writers in
the entirety of their runs while zoe 101
and drake josh had zero it also
references a scene that jamie lynn
spears filmed for her series zoe 101
which snyder created executive produced
co-wrote and even had a guest appearance
on in which she had goo quote roughly
the consistency of an egg white
splattered onto her face her co-star
alexa nicholas who we know she's been
very outspoken about her time quinn
no not quinn
uh nicole
no
the girl who was in the first season and
then never again she was always best
friends yes yes yes she recalled that
dan wasn't satisfied with that take and
made a crew member squirt her in the
face multiple times after jamie lynn
caught the goo on her forehead during
one take at which point it started to
dribble down to her face and into her
mouth which led crew members and
spears's even her mother erupt into
giggles she recalled one of her male
co-stars saying it's like a [ __ ] shot
before noting that the most sexualized
take was the one selected for the
episode the article goes on and on with
instances like this um and also
references jeanette's book where she
writes about the creator she references
dan by name and talks about how he
pressured her into drinking alcohol at a
young age and gave her some massages
that she didn't want
so i feel like it's pretty much been an
open secret for many many years that dan
schneider
was extremely nefarious
during his the height of his time on
those nickelodeon shows it's important
to know like dan schneider is so
rich and so litigious that i think it's
really stopped this story from becoming
like a major major story for that reason
and what was i going to say um hold on
it was important oh
and so while none of this is a surprise
i do feel like a huge part of the
conversation that needs to be had is
like
for abuse like this to go on for so long
without real repercussions like so many
other people are also responsible
including dan schneider but not limited
to literally everyone every executive at
paramount who let this behavior just
slide who didn't take extreme
precautions in a television show for
kids by kids like the way that even when
it came to a head a couple of years ago
and they very quietly just
not even fired like he let him retire
the way that like everyone at this
network has time after time
protected dan schneider is so
[ __ ] up it's so unethical and then it
also makes you think like
why yeah not to be like a conspiracy
girl but why no and who else is
involved involved why wouldn't you know
the executives of a kid's television
network not have the kids
well-being and safety their number one
priority no network wants a scandal let
alone a network that hires mostly
children
yeah
oh it just makes me so [ __ ] sick the
way kids are treated i know there's
never any justice in all of these places
that are supposed to be like kid
friendly visions or havens for kids or
literally intended to protect kids i was
just reading this book before we were
yours and it's from a while ago what
happened but it was
egregious abuse in these orphanages of
children children who were kidnapped
from loving parents in some situations
to be given to like and sold to richer
parents but
in the orphanages like
horrendous abuse over 500 kids were
probably murdered during their time
there was no never
to be seen again no record of them
exists like
we see with like usa gymnastics right
right these institutions that are
supposed to be looking out for
kids like we see it with failing
trafficking
yeah no it's [ __ ] terrible it's so
terrible like if you are someone who
abuses or mistreats kids like you are
the nastiest scum of the earth and if
you're someone who doesn't
who does anything whatsoever to protect
someone who would do that and you are
just as bad you are just as bad because
kids can't can't
stand themselves they can't protect
themselves they don't it's for the
adults to do it makes me [ __ ] sticks
to my stomach me too and i saw the
craziest [ __ ] thing on the internet
like i was shook
what'd you see
i saw a video of somebody sharing you
know talking about pedophiles
but preferring to refer to them as minor
attracted persons i saw that too
um
maps maps yeah we're coming up with
fancy phrases we as a culture we have
lost it
if we can't even call it pedophile what
he is a [ __ ] pedophile yeah
you will never catch me
with maps
you're a pedophile in my book
not you
you know what i mean if you're a man i
couldn't believe that i'm like oh my god
academia has taken over like it was so
minor attracted persons people are not
okay
no it's not okay
it's so sick and i'm glad this article
came out but like when i saw it i was
like a little like resentful almost i'm
like
now
yeah
what about literally 15 years ago when i
knew about it right we've like you said
we're in the secret like auntie's been
telling us for years yeah
and i feel like the
things described in this article maybe
because they're in scenes that you can
see on television so the litigiousness
it's like yeah there it is he's
extremely litigious i feel like this is
just the tip of the iceberg and
compared to like what we've heard
oh
beyond
and i think that like so and this i
don't know this for sure but i think and
especially from what i gathered from
jeanette's book is like
how you end up as a child actor has
so much to do with your parents
and so a lot of parents
i think it's it's split in the sense
that like some of them are extremely
protective of their child are there with
them all the way are watching out for
them every minute of every day and some
parents want it so bad
and they'll do anything for their kid to
be famous and for their kid to start
making money that they start blurring
the lines of ethics and
and it's a thing where like these
powerful people like a dan schneider
know that and they take advantage of
these vulnerable people yeah
it's just it's [ __ ] horrible and
honestly this article didn't even bring
me like a feeling of justice it just i
honestly felt resentful yeah like we're
talking about it now when he's off the
network it's
it's there's no stakes
if they wanted to do some investigating
like let's find let's look into the
people who covered it up the the
executives who let him you know quietly
retire who are probably still working
there right
who probably make literally seven
figures right who so who if they didn't
care to protect children 15 years ago 20
years ago what what's going on with the
children now right
right
and like everyone's a pedophile
literally what is wrong with everyone
sick sick
sick
well switching gears to some light
gossip which is our favorite kind me too
like so good because there are rumors
going around that tom schwartz and
raquel hooked up at sheena's wedding
yeah and now katie maloney is quote
blaming sheena for this pairing
so page six can exclusively reveal that
katie is blaming sheena from for tom
schwartz's recent hookup with raquel
levis quote raquel and schwartz 100
hooked up during sheena's wedding a
production source told page six
acknowledging the catalyst for the
current vanderpump rules drama
katie is mad at china because she
believes sheena is responsible for
raquel and schwartz hooking up thesaurus
notes that rockell and schwartz are both
super easy going and can be a bit
passive at times so who was going to
make the first move the insider asks
adding cakes actually so true adding
katie thinks sheena's encouragement gave
raquel and schwartz the green light to
explore a connection the source goes on
to say that katie is very annoyed over
the situation and not because her
estranged husband is exploring other
romantic connections in the wake of
their divorce she's just annoyed because
he decided to hook up with a girl in
their circle of friends and she's
blaming sheena
okay so she's definitely like has every
right to be annoyed like that the first
girl he hooks up with is like in the
group i don't know if it's really fair
to blame sheena and it's possible that
china was encouraging it but sheena
didn't shove their heads together and
may force them to start making out like
everyone was responsible for their own
actions
yes
but now some things are kind of starting
to piece together because katie wasn't
at her wedding
right was she invited did she not go is
she really mad at china is this the
first time tom and raquel have hooked up
like i love katie maloney and i don't
want her to
be in pain
but
i also kind of [ __ ] i think that they're
a good match 100 okay
i do think that they're a good match i
think that if they ended up together
they would be extremely happy together
but that doesn't change that they have
to be respectful honestly like this was
a marriage it wasn't a a breakup of a
boyfriend girlfriend it was a marriage
we're not messing around and that must
be really tough and now it's like
with the show
it's a one thing for tom to move on and
bring a new girl into the group and that
but like it adds a layer to be in the
same group and it's just a lot
and do that james cares
probably yeah because james has a new
girlfriend i imagine for katie like this
must be so emotionally
taxing
yeah be on a reality show to be going
through a divorce your man has a new
girl all of these things are already
taxing and then it's someone that you
like are very close not your best friend
but like someone but she's in your
circle and she's younger and she's new
like and you see her like every day and
your friends are friends with her like
oh my god
it can't feel good no but i should
but i do think it's a good match yeah i
agree 100
um
and not to be one of these people
because i literally hate these people
but it does sound like it'll be a good
season
i i will reserve judgment for until i
see something but i'm so
i am so
and i know this is going to make some
people unhappy i am so over bravo as a
whole we say this like every day at this
point no i always say like certain
franchises like
generally like i used to literally turn
on the tv my channel is 18 and like my
fingers would just go to 18 like it was
ingrained i've been watching
since i was literally in the 10th grade
like it's a part of who it's a part of
my personality it's part of who i am
when i say like when i see news stories
about the housewives or any like i can't
[ __ ] stand these people
i i think it's like
now i think now i kind of look at it as
how like other people like used to look
down on us
for like being obsessed like people who
are obsessed i'm like get a life
like and i know that's like beyond
hypocritical because that literally was
me up until
and maybe i'm just going through like a
negative phase where like everything is
pissing me off okay but especially the
fans like the the people who engage in
bravo i want nothing to do with them
like i don't want to have anything in
common with them i think they're
mentally ill i want no association with
them i think they're really like
embarrassing and tarnishing to bravo's
brand yeah i think it's a lot of things
that are happening at once one the fans
i think bravo is also like always
well we talk about all the time hello
bravo really has no scruples there's
really no rhyme or reason behind like
one decision that they make versus
another and there's no
consistency but i think also having not
had to watch these shows for the last
few weeks because i was moving and so
you were able to just like get your life
back and then have yes perspective and
be like okay when i'm not watching
beverly hills every single week like it
literally doesn't affect my life
whatsoever yet i see all these news
stories about like lisa rana said on
instagram and then she'd like someone's
posting sorry i feel like i want to like
make my statement about bravo and not
include the real housewives of beverly
hills because i still feel like it's
really good okay well it could be about
any franchise where it's like it's news
that someone like
leaves a comment it's like when there
are
there have been over a hundred house
wives never forget peggy sulhanian was a
hundred who could and that was so many
years ago
and when every single one of them like
every small social media thing like
becomes news it's unbelievably fatiguing
for sure and there are all of these huge
moments where we're supposed to be so
excited and amped up like girls trip you
know uh yeah and he's baby shower
theresa's wedding and it's like
there's still so many of them that it's
hard to get excited about one particular
thing and it just it falls flat more
often than not
i think it's like these big moments
yeah i think so too i think we're
growing up at the same time that the
shows are in decline so
there has to be some sort of parallel
yeah there's a parallel
but anyways
and i do feel that way about vanderpump
rules which is why this storyline
actually yes sounds interesting helpful
yeah to the show 100
are you ready for our next story
yes oh sorry speaking of bravo carl and
lindsay are engaged oh is that the story
yeah i'm happy for them
i
can't understand
i'll take the plane
in the truth me and my heart will make
it through
oh are you done singing uh i am because
i ran out of lyrics
and i wouldn't talk about this story
because i just realized something
remember we did that episode on patreon
which everyone should listen to like
things that people do that give you the
ick of course social media
one of mine is when someone like posts a
picture of their engagement ring and
says he did good
i don't disagree i don't disagree
i mean there's also a lot of icks around
social media when it comes to
engagements because they're like these
tropes like i did a thing
i said yes like there's a lot of like
cliches that people use so it's hard to
be original when it comes to like
engagement content on social media yeah
it is but
live your life and if he did do good
like who cares what i think but yeah
totally like you're happy right like
that doesn't mean you can't say it
anymore it's just something i'm just
like a negative wedge
and when she's gonna wench you know when
she's gonna venge well lindsay i just
want to say did not say that she said
and she actually said something really
sweet she told people this is the most
incredible thing i've ever laid eyes on
except carl oh that's sweet
she is like so obsessed with him so
you'd love to see somebody out here like
getting their love requited do you know
what i mean is that the right way to
phrase it it's the end of summer which
means that this will be on the show
and
um this is i think the turn that no one
saw coming no this is like a plot twist
like last season summer house he was
dating mackenzie
right season summer how he's engaged to
lindsay i'm curious if she is still
being sober with him because i actually
think sobriety is really like a good
thing for her yeah
she's just not a person who like um i
think
handles alcohol well
yeah plus i imagine that she is probably
still sober especially if he is yeah
and i like that i think actually if she
remains sober on summer house when we
watch it this season
um i think people
it might uh warm her up to a lot of
people
yeah myself included
yeah i think she's i'm really happy for
her though i think this is nice i think
it's nice too happy for them sorry that
their news had to wait till wednesday
yeah it was just like a busy week you
know
yeah and now are you ready for our fifth
and final story
the final story
hold on
let's try that let's try that again i
have my equipment oh
the final story
[Music]
we were good for your instrument
and that's a magic wenchie
how dare you
that's a magic wenchie
it is a magic wenchie that was not our
finest work no it really wasn't and i
liked the acapella version but i'm not
going to stop you from your art
thank you so much literally never i
appreciate that i appreciate that as you
should life is important it's so
valuable our fifth and final story is a
little it's very fifth and final story e
it is what is the most dream song of
summer 2022 what's the song in the
summer y'all spotify's got the data let
me think let me think i love spotify and
their data like i'm so appreciative yes
and
personally i would never really have i
wouldn't i wouldn't have guessed these
honestly
okay so is it um
like uh international like a latin song
like a rosalia or a bad bunny no okay
because only then i'm not like super
well versed
in that type of music so i would like
not be able to guess the top ones okay
so it's like
oh [ __ ] okay is it lizzo
yes
about damn time yes
wow look at me how many are there
there's three top three that um
depending on like global versus us so
that's what i got at three wow good for
lizzo
um
let me think what else popped off this
summer and honestly a lot of it i think
has to do with tick-tock
i don't know what are the other two
as it was by harry styles i'm so happy
for him and kate bush running up that
hill if i only could i'd make a deal
with god and i'd get him to swap my
places
i'm running up that road running up that
hill okay let me tell you can you google
when that song came out i'm pretty sure
it came out 10 years ago 1985 and it had
a resurgence because on tick tock no a
pivotal scene from stranger things
that's where it first got legs well then
it was on tick tock yeah so it is um
amongst the top three
songs is
kate bush alive
i think so and is she related to george
or jenna
or billy
or billy
she's a lie
well that's so exciting like what a
journey to like have a hit song and then
literally 40 years later four zero right
yeah yeah
to have it we started the summer i
didn't even know now when i saw that i
was like oh i feel like i maybe i've
seen that on rails a few times but i
didn't even know it was having such a
big moment because i don't listen to the
radio right i just like keep listening
to you and i wonder if they've been dumb
i wonder if they've been replaying it on
the radio have they i don't know if you
listen to tick-tock radio on siriusxm oh
yeah
which is all the tick-tock hits
i gotta get serious i gotta start
listening to you do it's pretty good
station
well i don't have a car so
yeah rub it in
the privilege is showing
i'm surprised elvis wasn't there or doji
cat or yes doji cat
or just jojo cat period like it's always
the summer of doja
zuma zuma zuma zuma let me be yours
will you let me be your zuma you are my
one and only zuma um what was your song
of the summer
that is a great question let me look
yeah let me look for in my spotify but
see for me like song of the summer
doesn't really have anything to do with
no but what song did you listen to on
repeat this summer that like when you
listen to it in a few years it'll remind
you of summer 2022
oh my god
this is like so random
should i play it or will we get
copyrighted what's the song
i don't want to i want it to play it
well that just means we won't be able to
monetize the episode but i think it's
worth it for a great bop
[Music]
i
want you to reach out
sagala came here for love with ella ella
ire so [ __ ] good reminds me of
platinum jubilee
okay so that's literally why i'm like i
obviously know this song but i need to
know it better when was platinum jubilee
like june right best day of my life june
yeah so i've been literally been
listening to it all summer and now i
went down to sagala you didn't know that
song before no did you listen to what i
said literally two seconds ago i said
obviously once you say platinum jubilee
i'm i mean somewhere else i said
obviously i knew it but like i don't
think i ever really like i knew it from
going on the clubs and the radio but i
never really sat down and listened to it
so then that sent me on a sigala journey
oh won't you see me yo sweet
the sound of the stone is a sweet melody
you know that one yeah like i've just
become a cigala girly you gotta go down
now
i like your journey and now i'm just a
sigurly
you gotta now do li or fantastic okay
well i'm in the process of cultivating a
playlist for my trip this weekend um and
i have like my
playlist that i always play when i'm
with brian and john and it's kind of
like like iconic gay anthems um with a
couple of personal touches doubt by mary
j blige a lot of celine dion but i
wanted it because we're gonna be on the
boat and like at the beach like it needs
to be so i added like
25 like cigala type songs like really
good like dance music and i feel like
i'm working with like the most
incredible playlist like i feel really
good about where i am that's so exciting
i'm really happy for you thank you what
is your song of the summer i think my
song of the summer is middle of
somewhere by luke homes
i just listen to it over and over sing
it over and over listen in the car it's
really coming for harry and it's also
it's also about like living in the
middle of somewhere and how it's like
you know your
little piece of everything
yeah no it's like everywhere to you
yeah and i feel like that's you know me
moving to the suburbs i'm in the very
appropriate way
out in the middle somewhere
yeah um that's a great song also you
know what song i just got really into i
know i'm probably behind
but 10 things i hate about you
by um leah kate
i know but you want to know how i found
it and i and now i can't stop
associating the song i
i
i hate that song what
you like it i love it i love this like
by the way and i'm saying this to you
privately but i love this like genre of
like poppy songs that's going really
vibral on tick tock that are like really
corny pop songs that like a b c d e f
you and your mom and your sister and
your job and your broke ass
that thing and
what i would have given back when i
listened to popular music for like those
songs to be like those are the songs
that i would listen to and like they
were never
on the radio oh i have a complete
opposite reaction to like this corny pop
genre that's coming from tik tok says
you're selfish i hate oh my god but when
we were maybe we were driving and you
started playing all these songs and i
was like this is what's popular these
days like i would have loved it's like
radio disney stuff oh for sure but what
when when i was playing that and i'll
tell you what song it was that's not
like the same vibe that was kate's
brother by maisie peters okay to me
that's the same vibe
no more selfish no i i
i have like a
physical reaction oh good okay and let
me tell you how i found the song and now
i associate it literally a grandmother
like it's beyond just wait till you hear
how i found the song so madison lacroix
reposted a fan reel by the way
everything in the world comes back to
madison lacrosse everything she reposted
a fan reel of ten you're selfish and for
each number they put it as a member of
southern charm yes yes yes so that's
selfish was craig and every time i
listened to the chorus i go through nine
year jaded is shep
eight is something about like dumbest
guy every day yeah awesome
let me guess let me guess okay what's
seven eight the dumbest guy i've dated
seven talk a big big game till you're
naked pringle
i was gonna guess oh sorry and that's
[ __ ] mean okay pringle definitely has
a big dick leave pringle alone okay six
seven talk a big game till you're naked
six you're toxic
five can't trust you four you've still
got daddy issues
yeah but there was also like six seconds
only six seconds and i had to fake it
okay do you know who that was you're not
gonna get this i'm getting confused
honestly only six seconds that i had to
fake it was jd
lol that's funny five you're toxic
naomi thomas oh catherine
thomas
four can't trust you naomi which was
surprising wrong what's three
five wait hold on
five yeah
four can check three you've still got
mommy issues whitney
ah
that's funny two
i don't know two was like a really long
thing i couldn't decipher catherine and
then one that you make me love you yeah
madison lacroix that's funny
um you're like so funny that like you've
like recently discovered like this most
ancient trend and like you're marveled
by the novelty of it it's like it's
actually really sweet i thought it was
obviously i like this song i probably
had heard it before it was not
unfamiliar but i didn't know that was a
trend and now every time i listen to the
chorus and i listen to it like on repeat
while i got ready this morning and i'm
just thinking like
chef austin yeah right you're funny
um
so those are the fast five you
definitely needed to know every single
moment of that
and the show's not over because it's
wednesday which means dear toasters our
advice segment where you can write into
deertoasters gmail.com anonymously we'll
take your name out and everything and
you can talk to your favorite girlies
about what you're going through so are
you ready for today's submissions ready
good because they're brought to you by
bowling branch they use 100 organic
cotton threads on earth for a superior
softness and a better night's sleep
their sheets are not just buttery
breathable and impossibly soft but they
get softer with every wash so i'm a
bowling branch girly as is jackie and we
both have the signature sheet collection
it comes in nine neutral colors in all
bed sizes from twin up to california
king you'll immediately feel the
difference of their iconic sheets
they're 100 free from toxins which means
no pesticides formaldehyde or other
harsh chemicals they also offer um
they also fit the deepest mattresses and
they're labeled with top and bottom tags
on their fitted sheets so making your
bed is no longer like a sweaty journey
it's just a normal
part of your life and for that we're
super appreciative um bowling branch has
been beloved by many us presidents and
two peabody award-winning podcasts so if
that doesn't kind of shake you to your
core i don't know what will bowlin
branch is a premium premium
linen and bed company i have so many of
their sheets but i also have different
like bed accessories like we both have
that waffle throw blanket that everyone
loves you can get 15 off your first set
of sheets when you use promo code toast
at bowlingbranch.com
that's
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast ready
dear jackson claude i'm going to get
right to it my husband and i have been
together for over five years married for
one year and we just welcomed a baby boy
over the summer he's a precious gem of a
man he's amazingly supportive and he's a
loving father but i write to you both
because
his teeth
he used to love drinking monster energy
drinks and i finally got him to switch
to black coffee just to be a little
healthier but now his front two teeth
are constantly stained they're
noticeably stained and i've brought it
up to him before when we're both
brushing our teeth but sometimes if
we're just having a quarrel my go-to
line will be well your teeth are yellow
it just comes out somehow i don't mean
to be mean but it truly bothers me and i
just don't know what to do he gets
defensive and thinks it's not a big deal
and that'll take care of it but he
doesn't he has a beautiful smile and i
just hate to see him not take care of
his teeth he interacts with people all
day and work at work and i just know
that they can see it too he can't seem
to be bothered or care to keep using the
whitening strips or brush more any
advice would be appreciated and i'll
definitely follow up with you
i was going to say whitening strips
because i used to use them and i think
they're fantastic they don't work for
everyone and some people really don't
like them but i do can i say one thing
without like
you know
i don't wanna
i don't wanna i just wanna
ask you to be mindful
of like your nagging because
you were nagging him about the monster
and so he did it he did what you wanted
and now you're like nagging him about
the teeth but the teeth are from the
coffee it's like
cut this man like a little bit of slack
like you're being like a little bit like
of a nagging naggy wife that's like
really true like he did what you wanted
and now the problem he has now sorry
it's your [ __ ] fault also do you ever
feel like especially when you stare at
the same face every day like with your
husband like he she's noticing it more
than his co-workers 100. but also it's
like would you notice that
i feel like i don't notice stuff like
stain no i'm i'm like always intrigued
in people's teeth okay maybe you're a
teeth person
i don't know if i wouldn't even notice
some people like are obsessed with other
people's skin
i happen to like i think the smile is
the focal point of the face like yeah i
get it um and there's definitely things
you could do i just want you to keep in
mind to like not really like annoy him
and piss him off because then he'll
never listen to you you know yeah but
part of being a wife to a man is
learning how to communicate with them
in this moronic way so that they'll do
what you want and currently you're
entering danger zone of naggy [ __ ] wife
you're also part of being married is
picking your battles
yes and i do think that this is a battle
worth having for sure you have to look
at his teeth every day and they bother
you uh you have to you know do the
speak the right language but maybe just
make him an appointment for a teeth
whitening session i think it's only like
one time and it'll clear right up or
like make one for yourself and be like
do you want to come with me like make it
easy for him that's what you have to do
with men like you have to literally wipe
their ass and drive them there and then
maybe they'll do it yeah exactly so if
you could do that dance just get him
there i don't think that it's not a
worthy journey i think like you should
totally get it fixed and we're gonna
help you do that but please listen to
what i said like
because if then your husband just
associates every time you like say
something as you like being annoying and
bitching to him he'll never listen he'll
never listen and like once you lose them
that's the worst once you lose their ear
yeah no
good luck to you and like getting it
back
yeah so like you have to
really be
extremely cautious in these scenarios
yeah you need to speak husband they
should that should be a language on
babel
like rosetta stone call it up like hook
it up yeah like babe like i love your
smile
um okay we're only gonna do one more
because it's a little long and it's like
kind of
complex it's like no it's not complex
but it's really get it's like pissing me
the [ __ ] off okay okay
dear jackson claude a few days ago one
of my best friends from high school i'm
28 years old called me with some random
news
she stated that she had heard through
the grapevine that my boyfriend of two
years ben
lent money to his longtime female friend
to help her with a messy situation and
financial predicament that she was in
me and ben have had arguments and
discussions about this particular female
friend before i too have known her for
many years and i've had my own
encounters with her prior to ever even
meeting ben
i don't like her and i don't trust her
plus they slept together once a long
time ago so it's just icky to me
however i've never asked him to stop
being friends with her because i believe
in my heart that there is nothing
nefarious going on between them also she
lives in california we've recently moved
to nashville so whatever
but when he came home i confronted him
and he admitted that it was true i told
him it wasn't the fact that he lent her
money it was the fact that i had to find
out from someone else and he
intentionally withheld this information
for me from for over a month
i felt dumb and i felt betrayed
he said he wanted to avoid upsetting me
and and avoid a fight it seems like a
stupid excuse though we talked cried and
eventually worked through it because
it's but it's been a few days and i
still can't help feeling a small pit and
just overall sadness it's the fact that
he had so many opportunities to tell me
and didn't i love ben i know he loves me
and i don't think that this is worth
relationship ending a relationship over
but i'm worried i will always be
suspicious or let my mind wander i don't
want to make this i don't want this to
make me insecure moving forward in our
relationship what should i do
i want to be happy and move forward in
my relationship
[ __ ] you're a bigger woman than me
because i think that this is breakup
worthy
yeah
money
is very
tricky
because you're not married so you're
obviously not entitled to like his
financial
history information
however
if that's the direction you're heading
then
it sets a really bad precedent like for
keeping
keeping financial information from you i
do not like that and that's not to say
that boyfriend and girlfriends need to
be completely financially transparent
with one another but like this is
something you would tell someone yeah
that
the fact that he wasn't financially like
transparent about such a big thing but
also just not transparent in general
like even if it was
twenty five dollars not to do with money
but just yeah he had some sort of say he
like went to coffee with her and didn't
tell you like
also the relationship that you're
describing between him and her it sounds
like the only reason why you're okay
with their relationship is because she
lives in california but like right
you should there shouldn't be someone
like in the background of your
relationship who also like would go to
your
boyfriend for money and who your
boyfriend would give it to
it's it's it's potentially nefarious
yeah it's not good money is [ __ ]
money's like next level it's only she's
going to him for advice or a place to
stay like
money i think it's weird i do and i is
she always going to come back to this
well is this going to be the only time
i think you have absolutely every right
to be upset still it would piss me the
[ __ ] off
and honestly dare i say i don't think
you're mad enough is she going to pay
him back was it a loan or a gift
now you have to get involved if he's
giving out gifts why don't you get a
gift no but that [ __ ] just pisses me off
because like
you know
girlfriends want to be you know why and
dying taken care of and it's like he's
spending that money on some other girl
who got herself into a situation like
it's not his problem it's not your
problem i need to know if it was a loan
or a gift and i need to know the
situation and i need to know the amount
also i'm just [ __ ] curious right like
what was the situation is it ransom like
what is it right like is she
behind her
like is it a
a worthy cause or she just you know
wants to go buy another bag and just
like and and or like she owes money to a
bookie or something she doesn't have
money because she's like spends her
money you know out in the clubs and on
purses and shoes right no i i the vibe
that i got was that literally um
she owes money to a bookie like a for
gambling right did she say gambling no
no that's not what she said at all that
was just the vibe that i got what she
had said help her with a messy situation
so a messy situation is not being low on
cash for rent like messy situation is
like someone's coming after you loan
shark vibes yeah
i think it's a bookie honestly like she
bet on the super bowl and lost
so he's also enabling
and like the worst part is that other
people knew when you didn't and you had
to get a phone call you looked stupid
right until there's when a partner makes
you look stupid now i'm upset right so
it's either that
he didn't tell anyone and she didn't
tell anyone oh no i'm sorry it's either
that he didn't tell anyone but like she
ran around like saying oh so-and-so's
boyfriend's giving me money
or he's telling other people and not you
yeah
um i hate to wrap this up but very
exciting news is that my boogle chair is
in the elevator in this building so i
have to go sign for the delivery i got
to show them the certificate of
insurance but i was going to wrap up
anyway so i hate to just cut you off but
i'm so excited for my buckle chair when
i tell you i'm gonna get a hemorrhoid
from this chair that i'm currently
sitting in it's so [ __ ] uncomfortable
my tailbone is like not okay okay so
to i just want to say tomorrow's episode
is the last episode of the week and it
will be audio only because i'm flying to
turks and caicos super early in the
morning so check out for a podcast from
us tomorrow and then we are back on
tuesday hope everyone has an amazing
labor day weekend enjoy the last bits of
summer soak it up and thank you so much
for listening to the morning to us the
money morning show where we do over the
past stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube
everybody watching this on youtube
please
subscribe to our podcast we found this
spider-man railroad castle please do a
little bit of fun this morning faster
everybody beautiful and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing day love
you jacks love you cleared bye